j'ai un orgelet voilà bon c'est quoi en
vrai un orgelet un orgelet c'est quand
on a une paupière gonflée comme ça on
appelle ça aussi un compè l'Oro ça
arrive quand on a une bactérie qui se
retrouve dans notre œil soit parce qu'on
met des lentilles de contact soit parce
qu'on s'est frotté les yeux par exemple
et ça cause une infection au niveau de
la racine d'un cil résultat ça gonfle et
il peut y avoir du pu HM c'est un
furoncle de cil en fait alors c'est pas
grave le plus souvent ça guérit tout
seul en quelques jours et c'est pas
contagieux c'est pas une conjonctivite
une conjonctivite c'est une infection de
la conjonctive c'est la petite membrane
transparente qu'on a sous les paupières
et ça si c'est viral c'est contagieux
attention c'est pas la même chose qu'un
chalasion non plus chalasion non mais ce
mot sérieux on dirait pas le nom d'un
journaliste de France 3 régions tout de
suite on retrouve el chalasion en direct
de Cholet un chalasion c'est juste un
petit kiste qu'on a sous la paupière là
c'est pas une infection je vous en
reparle une prochaine fois si vous
voulez